[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of fandango indie
movie Guide I seem to be on a little bit
of a horror-thriller dark movie kick
lately because I've got another three
twisted films for you to watch that all
being Alicia approved let's start with
the one that I spoke about at the
overlook Film Festival last week it's
the Aussie horror called hounds of love
[Music]
this is set in the 80s and it's about a
young girl who gets kidnapped by this
serial killer couple it is deeply
disturbing but very very smart that's
what I liked about it everything that
she does to try to escape is something
that is clever and interesting and
pausable
plus the way it ends I won't give it
away but I will say that the female
characters have much more to do with the
ending than you might expect in a movie
like this it's beautifully shot as well
by Ben Young who shows a real sense of
style he is a director to watch so
impressive for his first film and it's
really freaky for Australians to see
because the serial killer guy is played
by Stephen Curry who you would recognize
if you saw the castle but he's someone
who is well known for his comedy so to
see him in this light is extra creepy
and the fact that I believe him too he
completely transformed says a lot you
can see it in limited theaters and on
video on demand
[Music]
another twisted little film that you can
see on Netflix is called
small crimes I can't do anything about
before that's done I can show people
I've changed
would you like to take communion before
you go oh no I'm good this does Nikolaj
coster-waldau as the guys has just been
released from prison he heads back home
and he's searching for a better life he
wants Redemption but it's not long until
he gets twisted up in a whole nother
mess this is one of those movies that's
a real puzzle to put together and at
times it's a little confusing although
it comes together very satisfyingly at
the end it's directed by Al Capps who
did a great little indie film called
cheap thrills another one to put on your
list if you haven't seen it and here he
dives into those dark crime movies like
Fargo or something like a Coen Brothers
film possible to you that I might have
changed you do know where small crimes
is going and it does feel very familiar
like you've seen it before but it is the
perfect movie to watch at home on
Netflix this weekend check out more
crimes on Netflix second chance why not
and last but definitely not least
available on Fandango now is get out
city non-black shouldn't you make one or
you know mom and dad my black boyfriend
will be coming out this weekend just
want you to be shocked that he's a black
cynicism actress this is one of my
favorite films of the year incredibly
smart horror directed by Jordan Peele
there is so much going on in this movie
and I know it did really well at the box
office so many of you have probably seen
it but now it's available on home
entertainment I highly recommend
watching it for a second time because
you get much more out of it on a second
viewing casino brother mone
Chris was just telling me how he's
gotten much more comfortable with my
being here yo sorry man
get out yo there is so much that is
foreshadowed at the start which comes
true at the end I would love to look at
the script to just see how he put it all
together
it also has some very smart things to
say about race relations
it's not about overt racism it's about
the more subtle kind of racism feels
very very timely even though he wrote it
back in 2008 and shows John and peel to
be an incredible director as well as
writer he knows horror films and it
definitely touches on movies like
Stepford Wives and guess who's coming to
dinner
here is one smart cookie I can't wait to
see what he does next if you haven't
seen get out get out what are you doing
here so stretchy watch it at home this
weekend on Fandango now and like I said
if you've seen it already watch it again
brilliant brilliant movie there you have
it three little quick horror thriller
for you to watch this weekend you can
see hounds of love in theaters or on
video on demand small crimes is
available on Netflix and get out is
available to rent or buy on Fandango now
and that's it so this week I've got one
more episode coming at you next week and
then I'm going to be in kanne for the
film festival and I can not wait to take
you along sorry about that
I'm Alicia Malone I'll see you soon
you